sri lanka has reached crisis point
thousands of protesters have stormed the
presidential palace and taught the prime
minister's home so what happens now both
the prime minister and the president
have agreed to resign
sri lanka is facing its worst economic
crisis since it achieved independence in
1948. the island nation of 22 million
people has been left in financial
turmoil after economic mismanagement
and the impact of the pandemic and now
confusion over the change of leadership
their constitution usually dictates if
the president resigns the prime minister
in this case reynold wick remasinga will
step in and act in the office of
president
but the protesters have demanded both
the president and the prime minister
step down
however it's parliament and not the
people that elect sri lanka's next
president
the sri lankan parliament has said
they'll elect a new president by the end
of july
cabinet members say they'll also resign
once an all-party government is formed
only time will tell whether the handover
of power will be smooth or whether the
outcome will be accepted by protesters
and what about sri lanka's financial
woes
the international monetary fund said it
was hoping for a resolution to sri
lanka's political turmoil
to allow talks about a potential bailout
package to resume
there's unlikely to be any real progress
on that front until the country has a
legitimate president and prime minister
in place
but whether a bailout is the answer long
term remains to be seen
a tourism industry badly damaged by
suicide bombings and covert 19
severe foreign exchange shortages
limiting fuel food and medicine imports
record high inflation and vast
accumulating debts have all helped pile
pressure on an already cash-strapped
population
like many countries sri lanka has been
hit by the global fallout of the war in
ukraine and the ensuing fuel crisis
in a sense it's a bit of a canary in the
coal mine and the eyes of the world are
trained on sri lanka to see what it does
next
many people here blame the rajapaksa
political dynasty for the country's
economic collapse
the family has been in control of sri
lanka for two decades
months of protest in sri lanka reached
fever pitch when thousands of people
stormed the government district in
colombo when protesters broke into the
president's house many were angered by
the opulence of the soaring ceilings
four poster bed and vast marble bathroom
an indication of the gulf between the
countries rich
the resignation of the president and the
prime minister
may make many sri lankans feel that
months of hardship and demonstrations
have not been in vain
but what happens next with sri lanka's
economic future still hangs in the
balance